Oh
every day my dad's flying this thing
around and everybody and all the rooms
are staring out being like a signal
phone of welcome welcome a this
is not happening I'm going with junior
we all come from somewhere from someone
who nurtures us protects us and teaches
us some better than others
[Music]
[Applause]
- Antonio Hey ladies
[Music]
so my father was an illegal felon
anybody else is there anybody else in
here they alright if you guys don't know
what falconry is here it is so it's been
around for a couple thousand years and
it's basically people they kidnap
Falcons out of the wild and then they
train them to hunt for them now the
popularity fizzled out with the
invention of the supermarket we're like
hey man I don't know if we need a bird
of prey to bring us our supper anymore
we can just go to the meat aisle at the
grocery store but a group of lunatics
kept this tradition alive and my father
was one of them now here's the thing you
can't legally do falconry but you need a
license and in order to get a license
you got to jump through a few hoops
number one you have got to do a two-year
apprenticeship with a master falconer
now of all the people that I could spent
two years with I think master falconer
is probably at the bottom of that after
that you have to build enclosure for
this Falcon to live in then you need to
take a written test well my dad's like
that okay
I'm not gonna let the government tell me
what I can and can't do and so he gets a
book on falconry and he reads about
three chapters into it and then he comes
home with a baby Falcon
to this day I have no idea where he
actually got this Falcon from he claims
he found it while he was hiking through
the woods now I've done a lot of hiking
in the woods and I have never seen a
baby falcon just laying there looking
for a good home and it seemed like an
odd coincidence that he just happened to
be reading a book on falconry and he
finds a falcon either way he brings it
home but he doesn't have an enclosure he
didn't build an enclosure so here's what
he does he really no dog crate we have
in our living room and he throws it in
there now I have to admit as a kid we
have a pet Falcon it's kind of cool all
right I had a friend come over he's like
I just got a new dog and I was like I
see your dog and I raise you a
Falcon my friend get that dog out
of here but then something happens about
six seven months goes by and this thing
grows up and it is now a full-blown
bird of prey and I'll tell you this it
does not want to go back in the dog
crate anymore so here's what my dad does
he lets it fly around our house so right
off the bat we let our cats out one day
and they're like we're out of here like
you guys ride one of them I think
had like a stick with a handkerchief
with a shit-filled on it homo style and
just our dog all day long just hides
under the desk okay
he's traumatizing at PTSD but here's the
worst part
so this Falcon loved to perch itself on
our refrigerator right on the freezer
door so literally every time I went to
go in a Klondike bar I had to ask myself
what would you do for this Klondike bar
like is it worth getting a talent in
your nutsack for that delicious vanilla
ice cream chocolate-covered goodness one
of the scariest things is when you would
open the freezer door it would just
swing open with it and then just swing
closed
no change of expression on its face
whatsoever I don't know if it was
thinking of unicorns and rainbows or
think about mass murder of my whole
family now once a day my dad has to take
this thing outside in our backyard but
Falcons don't want to live in captivity
so here's what you have to do to keep
them from flying away you have to tie a
string to their leg give it some slack
and then hold on to the other end by the
way my dad had none of the falcon gear
that was necessary like you're supposed
to have a thick leather glove he had an
old oven mitt that's what he would carry
that's what he would carry it out into
the backyard with so we'd hold the other
end and he would let it go and so it
would it was basically like he was
flying a Falcon kite in our backyard and
it probably wouldn't have been a big
deal but at the time we lived in a motel
yeah so my parents thought it'd be a
good idea to buy a motel and then we
would live in an apartment attached to
it so every day my dad's flying this
thing around and everybody in all the
rooms are staring out being like is that
guys flying a Melvin and now
words traveling through our small town
in Indiana
that once a day you can watch a guy fly
a falcon behind our Motel and so now
we're scared that somes gonna happen
because here's the thing illegal
falconry if you get busted for it it's
not a slap on the wrist it's two years
in prison and a $50,000 fine that's
insane right you could kill a man and
get less than that I didn't know illegal
fowl crew was like that big of a problem
where they need to levy these sorts of
penalties so now we're freaking out
we're like holy if he goes to jail
there's not a lot of street cred that
comes with illegal falconry when you get
to the big house
like not a lot of tubes are like don't
rape that guy illegal Falconer he'll
you so that something happens so
little twist of fate happens ah so my
dad every day he would feed this thing a
live mouse so he goes to the pet shop he
gets a live mouse he puts it on the
living room floor and then the Falcon
flies off the top of the dog crate
swoops down and murders the mouse in
front of me while I'm trying to watch
Dukes of Hazzard just rips its insides
out so then one day my dad goes to the
pet shop and he tries to buy a mouse
they're all out of mice I don't know
what happened snake convention in town I
don't know how a pet shop runs out of
mice so here's what he does he has a
back-up plan he has some pork that's
thawing out his refrigerator so he feeds
the Falcon some pork Falcon eats it next
morning we wake up the Falcons dead I
don't know I don't know I think they're
Muslim or something I don't I don't know
the exact science behind it I don't know
so that my dad reads like three chapters
ahead and he goes oh you're not
supposed to feed him pork
so now we have this net Falcon which I
gotta be honest with you if you're
getting two years for just having a fly
Falcon if you murder one it's probably
way more than that so now we have to
wait for nightfall to come we march out
into the woods my brother and I dig a
hole we bury it like 10 feet deep and my
dad was just just so brokenhearted about
this he was devastated he's devastated
he thought that he was super tight with
this Falcon by the way and he
was not tight with this Falcon at all
it's not gonna give a about him but
my dad he never gave up man he tried to
get other Falcons unsuccessfully and he
passed away last year which is why I'm
legally allowed to tell this story now
but one of the last conversations I had
with him was in his backyard and he was
grilling and there's a falcon that
actually lived in his neighborhood and
it was soaring overhead and he was
looking up at it and then he just turned
to me and he goes I'm gonna catch that
and then he died thank you
guys
[Applause]